what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell the way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in and get yourself a
whim and shouldn't vote t-shirt today if
you are tired of the craziness tired of
all of these policies that women have
passed get yourself a women shouldn't
vote t-shirt today so you know guys when
I do these shows I really just like to
show common Trends in society
and I really want to show how in society
the men have gotten more feminine the
women have got more masculine and there
have been policies that oppress men
that have been passed by women that
really degrade the family unit and so
when I go through these stories what I'm
not trying to do is demonize anybody but
rather
show the consequences of our actions and
like what what these policies have
created you know we've talked about the
Logan Paul and Nina Agdal situation and
I will say you know Nina does she seems
like a really nice girl but the issue
was she was a model um in her early 20s
and you know spent her early 20s um late
20s around a bunch of celebrities
um really good looking chick dated a
bunch of guys and you know now it's
really biting her in the ass because now
she's dating Logan Paul and he's
fighting Dylan danis and Dylan danis
basically tweeting pictures of Nina
Agdal with other men every single day so
um there's been some updates in this
story so let's let's pull them up
so once the fight get in
October 14th chat let me know if this
happens man that's I don't know what to
do it's just recorder every day
it's a law fair bro that's what they do
that's what the this always been the
primary weapon of the Matrix law fair
they just attack you with lawsuits they
try and drain you financially and try
and distract you it's endless I think
Rogan doesn't want Minister wolf I think
that's where I'm at right now I think he
doesn't want to play me I think he's
just trying to get me to get to pull out
somehow so then he looks like the hero
you know I don't know it's
because this is all going through him
you know even if I win the case right I
still have to pay over four hundred
thousand dollars and just attorney fees
lawyer fees so it's like just
when I'm promoting a fight this is the
biggest fight he's ever done and or
event he's ever done and I made the
whole event like it's just man
you did make the event interesting I'll
give you that
that's so funny yeah um basically now
Dylan danis has been served with a
lawsuit and guys this is a a comment I
would say Modern Woman an emotional man
tactic where if you're saying something
they don't like they typically Sue and
it's one thing if they're saying
something that's not true into faming
you and I you know I have mixed feelings
on defamation suits I guess part of me
thinks you know freedom of speech is
freedom of speech but at the same time
you can't go around saying something
that's not true but I mean all Dylan
danis did was post pictures that are
freely available on the internet
um so Dylan danis has tweeted between
lawsuits and snitching this is a
straight up rat can't defend himself or
his hoe so he has to involve the law
what a coward
um so what do you guys think do you
think the lawsuit is Justified um my
take on it is
I I don't think it is I really think
that Logan did invite this by scheduling
the fight
but you know he wanted a troll and he
got a troll this is what he got it was
really interesting to see um Andrew Tate
and Dylan danis on a stream together I
thought they were so funny
um and Logan comes in he says
translation Predator see that's feminist
language all these words guys they're
just nonsense it's just feminism okay
Predator commits federal crime in
pursuit of stalking and harassing a
woman he's never met and is upset he's
held accountable
I did hear that he allegedly hacked her
Snapchat but I haven't seen any proof of
that Dylan danis says no federal crime
has been committed you're just listening
to the lives of your fiance in order to
save yourself image everything is public
and I will prove that it's not my fault
you didn't Google her name before you
put a ring on that thought and guys this
is the thing women are really really
good at manipulating men women like I
I don't know what she's telling him but
there's no way
there is no way you could talk your way
out of all of those I think he he
pictured her with like 50 something men
so Dylan danis responds and said I'm
actually flattered that she thinks I'm
smart enough to hack a Snapchat and also
as if years ago I knew they were going
to get married and kept them for this
moment okay so he's denying the Snapchat
allegations yeah I mean that does seem
far and what you see is lawsuit a lot of
lawsuits not all
um are really women just policing men
talking he into someone's had an
interesting take on it so let's pull it
up currently influencer Logan Paul is
scheduled to meet up with MMA fighter
Dylan danis on October 14
2023 not a big deal obviously there was
some trolling going back and forth but
then things sort of took a turn I would
say when Logan Paul decided to make a
comment on Dylan danis's girlfriend now
this is only relevant because Logan Paul
recently got engaged to Nina Agdal and I
want to talk about Nina Agdal and it's
in her entirety because I have known
Nina Agdal I have followed in the AG
doll I think Nina AG doll is absolutely
beautiful and Nina Agdal prior to
getting involved and she she didn't
herself say anything to Dylan Dennis but
prior to because of her attachment to
Logan Paul being inserted into this
fight was considered someone that I
think most people assumed was a high
value woman now why is this because she
is an actual supermodel she is a woman
that has walked the runway of Victoria's
Secret she notoriously dated Leonardo
DiCaprio I would say that was kind of
her first introduction to publicity it
seems to be some sort of a rite of
passage with supermodels obviously we
know Gisele Bundchen so think of her in
that Bay News Albanian people that have
dated Leonardo DiCaprio for a year I
don't know they age out when they're 22
or 23 he breaks up with them and they go
on to have an amazing career as a
supermodel Ina AG doll for all of
intents and purposes was one of these
women she has tons of sponsorships tons
of deals she also now operates her own
fitness program that's called the AG
doll method that is the reason why I
began following her because I love
Fitness obviously and this was a model
that was very much getting involved in
the Fitness World setting up studios in
the Hamptons and hosting classes when
Logan Paul decided to make a comment
regarding Dylan Dennis's other
well this is when things got really bad
for Nina Agdal I want to express that I
do actually feel bad for her all right I
don't think Nina Agdal is a bad person
and a lot of the clips that he Unearthed
that I don't think a lot of people had
seen uh or at least I don't think that
people had seen in such a rapid
progression are older she looks quite
young in these clips she looks to be
doing what I always talk about a lot of
women experiment with feminism in their
youth except a lot of those women don't
have cameras in front of them don't have
Instagrams don't have any level of Fame
and so they're able to grow up and say
you know what actually a lot of that
stuff was really trashy and I don't
actually believe those things I was just
doing what everybody else was doing
because it was popular and cultural in
that moment Nina Agdal is not a sex
worker Nina AG doll is not on only fans
selling her body she is a person that
was respected for being a supermodel and
respected for being a fitness model as
well for running as a small business
owner a company out in New York that is
training women to train their bodies all
of that right is now being impacted
because people are seeing her in a new
light so this is humiliating Fina Agdal
right this is a person that is being
impacted for the rest of her life what's
going to happen now if you don't think
this is impacting Logan Paul you're out
of your mind because men are mocking him
men are mocking him because they are
basically saying that your woman is
available to all of us look at all these
videos right they have demeaned her and
they have devalued her in the public
sphere so it's interesting how she said
they devalued her
it's like injured people have like
language slips sometimes they said they
devalued her in the public sphere but
really like she devalued herself in the
public sphere
um I do agree with what she's saying
where you know a lot of the a lot of the
wives of the previous generation would
have had similar Clips but there was no
cameras back in the day and you know
this is why I always say the truth
really does come out eventually sooner
or later and you know Candace is right
to be honest not everything that That
Glitters Is Gold and a lot of times you
you see you know men thinking they're
signing up for one thing and they and
they get another and guys I hate to say
it but this is why men like younger
women
so it'll be interesting to see we're
getting closer and closer to the fight
so I'm actually really excited to see